des mesures de sécurité renforcées ont
été prévues pendant le week-end devant
les synagogues cela bien sûr
à l'occasion de la commémoration du
premier anniversaire de l'attentât de la
rue copernic
la principale cérémonie se déroulera à
demain demain devant justement cette
synagogue de la rue copernic
faut-il rappeler qu'après une enquête le
mystère de cet attentat n'a toujours pas
été élucidée c'était il ya un an jour
pour jour presque heure pour heure
vendredi 3 octobre 1980 18h40 rue
copernic
une bombe de forte puissance explose
devant la synagogue de l'union libérale
israélite
bilan quatre morts et neuf blessés un
bilan qui aurait pu être bien plus lourd
si l'engin avait éclaté au moment de la
sortie des trois cents personnes qui
priaient à l'intérieur de la synagogue
après la panique après l'horreur la
réplique est unanime plusieurs
manifestations sont organisées l'une
d'entre elle regroupe près de cent mille
personnes
un seul slogan lutter contre la montée
de l'antisémitisme l'attentât en effet
été immédiatement revendiquée par la fan
la fédération d'actions nationales et
européennes l'extrême droite se retrouve
sur la sellette même si l'un de ses
leaders mark rubrique sel ni la
paternité de l'attentât de nombreux
sympathisants néo nazis sont interpellés
puis relâchés
la police est également en cause les
syndicats dénoncent son infiltration par
des éléments d'extrême droite
l'enquète n'avance pas la faire elle
prend un tour résolument politique le
gouvernement de l'époque est accusée de
laxisme le ministre l'intérieur d'alors
christian bonnet répond que l' enquête
pourrait s'orienter vers d'autres
directions
les accusations se multiplient une
faction de l'extrême droite met en cause
moscou tribune juive indique kadhafi
mais il n'y a pas d'élément étayant la
piste libyenne et puis l'enquète semble
avancer un peu on retrouve le nom du
propriétaire de la moto piégée
c'est la piste chypriote mais là aussi
les indices sont très faibles
les policiers se lancent alors sur la
piste espagnole des suspects sont
trouvés parmi l'extrême droite ibérique
ils seront mis hors de course l'afer est
devenu international et cela complique
le travail de la police française c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles la
question qui sont les assassins restent
sans réponse
un an après l'attentât